je fais confiance confiance à la science
je connais absolument rien
donc j'ai été vacciné tout au long de ma
vie par des diverses vaccins et je pense
qu'il faut faut faire confiance
est-ce que les gens qui demandent à
choisir sens assez calé en biologie ou
pour pouvoir demander pour pouvoir
choisir justement je pense qu'il faut
faire confiance à partir du moment où
les deux vaccins ont été homologués moi
j'ai pas de jets pas d'état d'âme sur
l'un plus que l'autre
les deux en plus ont un haut niveau de
protection sur modern art où biotech
donc pour moi j'ai pas d'état d'âme là
dessus alors ça s'inscrit dans une
priorité de vacciner le maximum de gens
et prioriser un vaccin plus que l'autre
ça peut éventuellement poser des
problèmes sur l'approvisionnement et
empêcher des gens d'être vaccinées au
moment où ils souhaiteraient le faire
quoi tout simplement comme tous les
produits que je consomme mais j'aimerais
bien avoir le choix évidemment
et j'aimerais bien être informé je pense
que s'il était aussi transparent que ça
on pourrait avoir le choix et ça peut
amener justement les gens à se poser une
question et donc avoir une certaine
défiance une certaine méfiance qui est
déjà bien présente
dans la population française quoi c'est
pas que ça me fait peur mais ça me pose
à m'interroger ouais encore plus que
cabon mois ne connaissant pas les choses
ça met un peu indifférent je comprends
que quelqu'un qui connaisse les vaccins
et un avis moi j'en ai pas donc je m'en
remettrai à ce qu'on me concert à un
moment je me vaccine ray s'il ya une
raison qui est d'accessibilité au vaccin
c'est à dire que lui moi mon avis le
plus vite on vaccinera l'union le mieux
on se portera donc si c'est pour pas que
les gens fassent de caprice en disant
non je me vaccine pas avec celui-là je
l'autre ça je peux comprendre si c'est
uniquement une question d'autorité sa
fatigue quoi je pense que ça c'est pour
mettre la concentration sur quel manque
de laboratoires et second choix sinon
est-ce qu'on joue aussi si on souhaite
c'est vacciner ou pas très honnêtement
non à part si un vaccin russe ou un
vaccin chinois peut-être mais mais non
parce que je n'ai aucune connaissance
dans ce domaine je sais pas lequel est
le mieux donc à part peut être une
cinquantaine une centaine de personnes
dans le monde qui ont la capacité de
trouver les différences je n'ai aucune
idée donc ça voudrait dire que parce
qu'on a lu quelque chose sur internet
on va se dire que telle la bo est
meilleur qu'un autre je pense que c'est
assez difficile d'avoir cet avis là je
pense que c'est une décision qui a du
sens puisque ça voudrait dire qu en fait
plus les arrivages arrive et plus on
arrive à vacciner les gens rapidement
qu'on a du mal quand même avoir une
autre vision que celle de bain d'une
vaccination collective pour qu'on puisse
reprendre notre vie au quotidien donc
non je pense qu'il faut pas laisser le
choix parce que ça voudrait dire
qu'après on va vouloir se vacciner que
si on a un bac c and fire ehpad
astrazeneca est en fait personne
personne n'est capable de dire les
différences
honnêtement je
la question pour moi c'est pas très
important puisque j'ai fait prendre le
choix c'est de ne pas le faire maxime et
moi que ça vraiment obligés par rapport
au travail ou éventuellement si pour le
voyage et parce que je souhaite voyager
dès que je pourrai dans l'absolu ce
qu'on passe à lanières décision devrait
avoir déjà qu'il ya beaucoup de
controverse autour du lac st il faudrait
après complice et au moins avoir la
possibilité de faire le choix